jean marc sylvestre bonjour bonjour
heureux de vous retrouver ce matin sur
le plateau de la matinale alors les
chefs d'entreprise est bien la campagne
présidentielle elle s'enlise dans la
médiocrité oui parce que les chefs
d'entreprise ont ont été un peu déçus
par la plupart des discours notamment
dimanche dernier par valérie pécresse et
chefs d'entreprise sont un peu comme
tout le monde vous savez ils attendent
un pouvoir de pouvoir choisir un
président et cette année les cartes sont
très brouillée il ya plus de gauche et
la droite est coupée en trois parties et
puis il n'ya pas de personnalité qui se
détache beaucoup attendent et valérie
pécresse c'est vrai mais on peut pas
dire que sa prestation sur la forme
comme sur le fond est d'aider très
convaincante et puis deuxièmement ils
attendent forcément des promesses pour
faciliter leur business c'est normal la
personne mais là personne ne trouve son
compte puisque ça part dans tous les
sens et puis la troisième fois ce qu'ils
attendent je crois un exercice de
pédagogie sur les grandes réformes à
faire et qu'ils demanderaient du courage
donc des explications en général une
campagne électorale ça sert à ça et bien
jusqu alors la campagne présidentielle à
tourner en rond à gauche à part jean luc
mélenchon qui propose un changement
radical de système
difficilement applicable il se passe
rien à droite eric zemmour s'est trouvé
un couloir de nage avec l'immigration et
ce couloir de nage le porte un
actuellement marine le pen essaie de se
crédibiliser entre la tentation
identitaire et les principes de réalité
valérie pécresse elle fait le grand
écart entre les thèses qui sont
défendues par eric ciotti très proche de
zemmour et les thèses qui sont plus
centriste pas très éloigné de macron
donc ce qui remonte à la surface ce sont
des propos assez violents sur
l'immigration des invectives sur le
pouvoir d'achat avec des querelles qui
sont assez ridicules sur les libertés
individuelles sur l'antisémitisme il
faut écouter yannick jadot le candidat
écologiste s'enfonce dans
l'antisémitisme 6 c'est quand même assez
j'allais dire lamentable mais oui tout
ça c'est d'un niveau assez médiocre il
n'y a pas de vue d'ensemble
il n'y a pas d' analyse sociologique ya
pas de l'analyse idéologique pas de
référence des petites phrases du
populisme on veut pas faire de
caricature mais la semaine dernière on a
quand même vu des images
la rencontre entre poutine et macron
cinq heures de négociations à moscou ces
images ont frappé tout le monde savait
quand même l'air sérieux et bien essayé
d'imaginer une rencontre identique avec
un des candidats actuels à la
présidentielle non ça ne fait pas cette
campagne est intellectuellement pauvres
parce que les candidats ne sont sans
doute pas à la hauteur d'où la démagogie
d'où le désintérêt des électeurs est
sans doute ce qui est beaucoup plus
grave l'abstention ça traduit d'ailleurs
l'appauvrissement général de la classe
politique française mais du coup je
remarque est ce que on sait ce qu
attendent eux les chefs d'entreprise oui
parce qu'il ya eu des réunions comme
celle de à laquelle vous faisiez
allusion et hier soir on sait que le
medef de geoffroy roux de bézieux
auditionne les candidats le mouvement
ethic sophie de menthon qui se remue
beaucoup a conviés également très tôt
les candidats à s'exprimer les patrons
n'ont pas reçu les précisions qui les
attend les chefs d'entreprise ont besoin
d'être rassurés parce que la situation
est fragile économiquement ça marche
c'est vrai parce qu'il ya un rebond
après le coc vide mais les chefs
d'entreprise sont lucides ils ont besoin
de savoir comment va rééquilibrer les
dépenses publiques comme on va absorber
la dette ils ont besoin de savoir
comment on va redresser la situation
internationale on n'a pas de réponse de
la part des candidats sur le crâne sur
le pétrole sur le nucléaire sur les
dépenses publiques sur tous ces grands
dossiers là qui devrait pourtant
concerné l'ensemble de la population
alors quels sont les dossiers les plus
urgentes alors très précisément où il ya
des dossiers qui sont finalement ni de
droite ni de gauche ils ont été recensés
ils sont défendus aussi bien par les
grandes et que les petites entreprises 1
il ya des impôts de production c'est
très toxique il pèse directement sur la
compétitivité tout le monde en parle
mais personne ne dit par quoi on
pourrait les remplacer deuxièmement il
ya la fiscalité verte ça c'est un vrai
problème l'écologie la contradiction qui
pourrait y avoir entre la croissance et
l'écologie tout le monde est d'accord
sur la transition écologique je crois
mais les clivages sont sérieux sur la
façon d'y arriver troisième dossier vous
avez par exemple dossier sur les
retraites il faudra relever l'âge de
départ à la retraite pas forcément pour
tout le monde mais pour la grande
majorité est là tout le monde est très
prudent parce que on craint une
résistance une révolte type d j les
jours 4 ben les dépenses publiques nous
sommes le pays qui a des dépenses
publiques les plus lourdes en europe
mais nous avons des services publics qui
marche très mal l'hôpital ne marche pas
bien l'éducation nationale marche pas
bien personne n'ose aborder cette
question alors au delà de ces quatre
dossiers il faudrait aussi revoir la
durée du travail arrêter de rêver sur la
réindustrialisation
et puis les graisser la bulle de la
bureaucratie alors vous allez les
candidats sont capables de faire des
diagnostics mais aucun n'a présenté au à
ce jour une solution alternative
cohérente et responsable alors on est
actuellement en campagne de premier tour
c'est vrai alors et chacun essaie
d'exister donc c'est ainsi radicale mais
chacun essaie de se faire remarquer il
va falloir aborder les vraies questions
sinon bah sinon les français vont se
dire à quoi bon voter puisque rien ne
changera après merci nous marquent les
liteaux écoute jean marc sylvestre c'est
tous les mercredis matin dans la
matinale a retrouvé bien évidemment sur
les réseaux sociaux